Good afternoon,
everyone, and Thank
you very much for having me.
I'm sorry not to be with
you in Washington DC,
but joining you virtually.
And so, I'll kick on,
talking about scaling
and automating our workflows
with Kubernetes and Airflow.
I spent a lot of my childhood
and teenage years working
on farms, and any of you
who will have done the same
will recognize baler twine.
Now the joke goes that you
can solve 90% of your problems
on a farm with baler twine,
and this is essentially
nylon string that you'll cut.
There's an off cut from or
kind of a byproduct of tying up
bales of hay, but
it ends up being
a useful tool in tying
together, say, a farm gate
or trailer to an ATV or
even a lead for your dog.
It's something that's lying
around that's tough and sturdy
and largely gets the job done.
And the equivalent, I
guess, would be duct tape.
And as you can see and as many
of you will have experienced,
duct tape isn't really
the appropriate tool
to get the job done
here or in many cases,
but it sort of works
and it's sort of OK
up to a certain point.
But then the farm
analogy really is
that you can get so far with
baler twine, but at some point
you're going to need
real infrastructure,
bricks and cement.
And so that's what I'm going
to be talking about today.
So who am I?
I'm an infectious
disease epidemiologist
working at the UK
Health Security agency,
or what used to be called
Public Health England.
And like many of you, I imagine
at the RStudio conference
today, you'll have
been an analyst
of some sort in a
particular specialist area.
And as you've fallen presumably
further in love with R,
you've ended up becoming more
of a proper data scientist,
as it would have been back then.
And then you and, I think
this will be a familiar story
to other that people
have gone through,
or the people will hope
to be going through,
or will inevitably find
themselves going through,
is finding themselves not having
quite the right tools either
for their specific area or more
likely just end up, becoming more
of a software
engineer as they're
trying to create the tools
for themselves and colleagues
to work.
And then once you've
got those tools.
And as we heard
in the last talk,
you're often it's not the
tools so much that are lacking,
but the data.
And so you end up finding
yourself, spending
all your life
moving data around,
cleaning it, linking
it, preparing it.
And then you may as
well be a data engineer.
And then the final
stage of transformation,
as you get further and
further away from analysis,
is when people start to presume
you're a member of your ICT
department and you
fancilly decided
to refer to yourself
as a DevOps engineer.
Now this all boils
down to, in my case,
having a profound love for
both epidemiology and for code.
But it's taken,
a lot for me to
find this area where
I am in now, which is enablement
of my colleagues and I to,
analyze epidemiology and
infectious disease data
at scale.
So what am I going
to be talking about?
Exactly that.
So how we replaced our
baler twine like solutions
are they sort of
work, but we need
them to be a bit
better solutions
with true infrastructure and,
clicking on.
I'm going to be talking
about those main tools
that we've ended up using.
So why Kubernetes and what even
is Kubernetes at this point?
And then what do we
mean by automation
and why is it valuable?
And then Airflow and
why it is actually
and why it's solved so
many of our problems.
So the context for
all of this, which
I imagine will be familiar,
but it's important nonetheless
to buzz through, is that
public health agencies
have traditionally worked
with maybe hundreds of cases
of each infectious disease
they specialize in each year.
These are small data sets.
They're easy to manage for
simple analytical tools
and those traditional
ones and the more
modern ones like R and Python.
So there's never
been an impetus per se
to begin to think about
scale or automation is
you're not working at
breakneck pace per se.
And the turning point
for this in recent years
has been that both
data that is captured
and the answers that we're
required to provide to decision
makers and health protection
colleagues on the ground
is becoming more detailed
and more complex.
And in the UK, Thanks to
our National Health Service,
Health Service, where care
is free and standardized
to a certain extent and we have
collected fantastic volumes
and quality of
data from it, we're
needing to understand
it in much more detail
than we ever had before.
So scale has started to
creep in, but of course
the - clicking on with my slides -
We're at this point
where we're needing
to do more complex
analysis, and so we're
using more appropriate
tools for moving away
from those kind of legacy
tools that many of us
would have been taught in our
infectious disease courses
at University for those
epidemiologists in the room,
but are quickly
becomes the lingua
franca for our topic area.
It's open source,
it's accessible
and it's usable to
all of us, and it
answers all the questions
that we needed to.
Now, COVID is
where we've started
to blend both that
much more complex data
requirements into needing to
work at unprecedented scale,
going from hundreds of
cases up to millions
of recorded cases in the
UK or confirmed laboratory
confirmed cases.
And so we've needed to move
away from those traditional ways
of working.
And so some people will
say, well, just use SQL
and you'll be fine.
But as we'll all
know, SQL will only
take you a certain
way before you
need to be able to wrangle
your data in a much more
flexible and accessible way.
And so although ODBC
powered workloads
kind of creep in to increase to
your script and your processes,
really just need to be
able to do R, but bigger.
And that's where
we come to today.
Now the final context is that
and all of our colleagues
who work in the public
sector will know
is that you have a
requirement to work
with high value for money
and have it maintained
by rather small, small teams,
the small but mighty teams that
exist in many public
sector organizations.
And then also you're expected
to perform at least the industry
standard, if not further ahead.
And all of that leads to
quite strong innovation
in many cases, it's
really a sink or swim,
and that's really the, COVID was
the sink or swim moment for us.
Now in the UK we're very
lucky in that the UK
government prefers open source.
It's a written down,
kind of truth that in order
to be achieving high value
for money, you need to
be using open source
technology where possible.
And so that was really
quite a nice gateway
into us using these
fantastic tools.
So where have we come from?
We've come from
a place of people
running an individual script, in
a standard operating procedure,
and then maybe thinking, OK,
I'm going to write all of this
out instead and run
it on a scheduled
task on my laptop
for a Windows users
or a cron job for
our Unix users.
Setting up the scheduled
task on the virtual machine.
When your laptop started
to feel a little bit robust
if needed to have your
laptop on all the time.
And that's really the beginning
of where the baler twine
solution start to
creep in, and you're
finding yourself wrapping more
and more of your solutions
in bits of tough nylon string,
trying to keep it together.
And that's when
you need to start
pushing into having
that place of having
more robust infrastructure.
So you might set up a cron job
on an older tool like Slurm,
or if in more modern
cases on Kubernetes.
And then finally getting to
that true infrastructure,
having both an
orchestration tool
and a compute tool of
having your DAGs in Airflow
running on Kubernetes.
And I'll explain what
those mean at the moment.
So what is Kubernetes?
What are we talking about?
So Kubernetes first
is open source.
It's a Cloud Native
Computing Foundation
tool that's become pervasive
in running typically
web apps, but now increasingly
data science workloads
across the world.
Now the use of
container images moving
away from well it
works from my machine
to therefore shipping the
entire operating system
and all of your system packages.
And those container
images popularized
by docker, which everyone
will have heard of
and they're slightly less
popular, but increasingly
upcoming podman tool providing
very similar functionality.
And Kubernetes extends that
idea of running your workloads
in container images.
And instead of having those
container images running
on your laptop, they
allow you to orchestrate
having those container
images run anywhere.
So you could have
Kubernetes on your laptop,
you could have it anywhere.
And I come onto
that in a moment.
But you specify your software,
your operating system
in your container
image, and then
you apply resources,
your compute your memory,
your storage into in your
pods and run those together.
Now, pods are entirely
isolated, which is either
very helpful or not helpful
at all, in which case
you can configure them to not
be isolated from each other
very specifically.
But it provides that great deal
of security and reassurance
that your workloads can
coexist in whatever environment
that you have created.
Now the UK Health
Security Agency,
we prefer the Red Hat flavor of
Kubernetes known as OpenShift,
and I'll talk a little bit
about that now because it's
easy to use
continuous integration
and continuous delivery.
It has those add-ons
and I think everyone,
particularly those are
RStudio on our posit fans
will know that using
open source tools
is certainly cost effective.
But there does
become a time where
paying for the expertise
and the tools that
are enabled, enable the easier
use of those open source tools
is really worthwhile,
and that's certainly
the case with OpenShift
in our opinion.
So that continuous integration,
continuous deployment
is more of a DevOps term, but
to the user, what's important
is that you can have your GitLab
or GitHub repository containing
your code, and whenever you
push your master branch,
say, that code is replicated
into your container
image in Kubernetes or
OpenShift ready to go
running just as it
would do on your laptop
and allowing you to push
that workload into whatever
literal environment you want.
Now why have we used it?
And that's primarily
because you want
to use fewer resources,
because instead
of having a virtual machine per
task configured just the way
you like it, you can figure
for each of your workloads
exactly the operating system.
The system packages your code
in any of your connections
all into one bundle.
And you can put
that onto one place
and then use fewer volumes
of compute and storage
capacity, which is going
to be saving money.
So increasing that value
for money as a start-up,
it's also easier to manage
for ICT administrators
and I think all of us will
feel either hamstrung or very
sorry for our ICT
colleagues, particularly
in the public sector,
where you want
to make their life as easy
as possible so they can make
your life as easy as possible.
And having all of your workloads
standardized or at least
with a standard
definition, is incredibly
helpful for the simplify
management of those resources.
And the other great thing
about Kubernetes, as well as
it being open source, is that
it runs anywhere. You can have
it available in the public
cloud, like Azure
or GCP, in the hybrid
cloud, if you're
from a larger organization
or on premises
or even on your own laptop
when you're doing development.
And then Kubernetes,
as I said, is frankly
already the way forward
or increasingly pervasive
for running containerized web
applications and microservices.
And although data science
is lagging behind,
it's got a lot of
tools and projects
that are propelling into being
more and more commonplace.
So then Airflow, the
second piece of our puzzle
or the second piece of our true
infrastructure solution
and again is open source from
the Apache Software Foundation.
It's a workflow scheduler,
which means that you
it's similar to a cron job.
And one of the funniest ways
of ever being described as it
was when it was described as
Apache "Fancy cron" as opposed
to Apache Airflow or
maybe Cron++.
Because it gives you not just
scheduling something to say,
I want to run this command
at 7 AM every day,
seven days a week.
You can say not
only that, but also
email me when there's
a problem or I
want to see all of
the details of how
which days it succeeded,
which days it failed,
how many times it
tried to retry itself.
And so on and so forth.
It's just got those added
extras which give you,
instead of having a
myriad of tasks and custom
scripts with their own
monitoring and logging in them,
Airflow offloads that.
So anything that you
can offload all of that
thought to Airflow itself.
Now you define your workflows
in directed acyclic graphs
or DAGs as more
commonly referred to.
And now DAGs is not
an uncommon phrase
to those in data science.
If any of you use any of you
use the targets R package,
you define your
work in a DAG also
those who work in machine
learning quite often
will have this.
But for those who
don't know, a DAG
is simply a set of tasks and
the relationships between tasks
that show the dependencies
between one thing
having happened and the
next thing having happened.
And Airflow manages all
of its workloads in DAGs.
Now DAGs and Airflow are
very simple because you have
a simple code as configuration.
Although it's written
in Python to an R
user who hadn't written
any Python before he
started using Airflow,
it's remarkably simple, so don't
let that certainly put you off.
And then this allows
you to do anything
from as simple as
running an R script, just
an arbitrary, arbitrarily
defined hour script to setting
up Airflow to be
linked to your Hadoop
cluster or any
other large compute
cluster or other
data processing tool.
Now, Airflow is
incredibly flexible,
which is fantastic
because it fits
a wide variety of use cases.
But at UKHSA
we've defined, to define that
into a very
opinionated setup, not
making use of much
of that flexibility
and instead trading that
for a user friendly simple
to learn state, which I'll go
into detail more about now.
So how have we use
these together?
How have we melded
these together
and why is that useful?
So each team has its own
Kubernetes namespace, so-called,
or a project if you're using
OpenShift specific language
and that allows you to define
users, resources, security
and other details about
all of your workloads
that mean you can have
tenants, different teams
within the organization.
And many, both public sector
and private sector teams,
will know that not everyone
in your organization
should see all of your data.
You've often got
to specify it down,
so having those
individual tenants
within your organization
is incredibly helpful
and also just allows you to
make sure no one's getting
in their own way or getting
in each other's way even.
And then in, when you integrate
that with Airflow, you
have all of your container
images, all of your code,
all of credentials,
all set up in air,
in OpenShift or Kubernetes.
And then you assign
each DAG to a project.
So a team or a team in their
own project or namespace
can have multiple
DAGs, but each tag only
looks at it only belongs
to a certain team.
And that's been remarkably
helpful as well for making sure
people aren't confused by which
workload is failing, which one
isn't, if it's theirs or not.
And then teams
therefore can only
see their own project
and their own DAGs
or their own projects and
OpenShift and their own DAGs
in Airflow, which again helps
keep things simple and secure.
PowerPoint letting me down.
And then within that we say
every Airflow task rather than
each different task being
a different operator
as they're known in Airflow.
Each task simply creates a new
pod in Kubernetes and OpenShift
with your container image,
with all of your code,
and then you give it
a specific command.
And most often in my
workloads, that command
is simply to run an
R script, because we
offload all of the connections
to our other resources
or secrets credentials
to Kubernetes,
where that enterprise
level security and resource
management happens.
And then Airflow is
simply telling Kubernetes
how to run a pod and
with what resources.
And this is what we found
to be after a lot of battle
testing and user acceptance
to be the most simple,
secure and easy to manage way
to move workloads from people
running individual
scripts on their laptops
into Kubernetes and
Airflow, which saves,
as you can already
imagine, you don't
need me to spell out vast
amounts of staff time
and also observability,
making sure
that the entire team knows
when something's happened
rather than needing to send
teams or Slack message to ask,
have you run the
script for today?
So the important event is
how do you get started?
Well, if you haven't
already got started,
you can use the popular
and although not open
source kind of in
the case of docker,
but tools like Docker and
podman to write and build
your container images and then
your or working containers
to start with a tool, now
Red Hat with its commitment
to open source allow provides
these free developer licenses,
which means that you can
have your own OpenShift
cluster on your laptop,
which is the perfect way
to get started with learning
how the system, how Kubernetes
works itself with these user
friendly, easy to get started
add-ons that the OpenShift
flavor of Kubernetes provides.
Airflow, as we said,
was open source.
It's simply a Python package.
You can pip install
it very happily
and then begin
playing with your,
with simple DAGs
in half an hour.
And then when you want to go
to the next step, how to use
or using OpenShift
Kubernetes yourself,
you're using Airflow yourself.
It's then time to instead
of having Airflow
on your own computer
put onto Kubernetes,
you have the official
prebuilt container
images to run
Airflow on Kubernetes
or on your own computer.
And then after that, when
you've got your workloads
with small amounts of
resources on your own laptop,
you can say, OK, I'm
ready now to move on
to the main Kubernetes
cluster.
And that takes you from
the 8-16 gigabytes of memory
and 8 CPU that have on a laptop up
to as large as you can possibly
achieve with the hardware
that we currently
have in terms of your compute.
Now extra tools that you
might want to know about.
There are a couple that
will really help you
in this kind of very high
level summary of this massively
complicated topic,
both the rocker project
providing container images
with R installed and ready
to use or so.
And I'm not just saying
this because we're
speaking at the R
RStudio conference,
our studio's public version
of its Package Manager
has been enormously
both time saving
and helpful for having
R package binaries
for Linux available
to the public.
It's a truly wonderful resource
which I couldn't recommend
highly enough, but then
actually if you're just
wanting to get started with
Kubernetes, not in a production
sense, but in terms of
doing your own development,
the absolute best
way to be learning
and to moving your development
workloads into Kubernetes,
into the cloud is using RStudio
Workbench, which I couldn't
endorse more thoroughly.
And I know that I've
come up to time now,
so I'm going to hold there.
And Thank you very
much for listening.